there's a lot of red pill blue pill all
this stuff saying RP and I'm like what
is RP looking it up so if we can clear
up the muddiness because I know that
that can get lost right there's a lot of
misinterpretation of the red pill blue
pill and some people are actually saying
that you misinterpret the red pill me
but first of all yeah I don't even know
what the red pill is no don't explain
that it's funny because thank you David
I thank you for that they're lucky
because I I don't read comments
I don't read comments never have I mean
I used to back when you know garyvee
would tell me to read comments but
really yeah but now I got to a point
where I don't read comment so and why
don't you do that yeah
to me it's a false representation of how
people really feel because you're like
Amplified yeah because the thing about
it is do you comment on videos I never
have do you comment on videos I have I'm
being I'm not disrespecting anybody
who's in the comments today I have not
met a person
who's doing well in life who
consistently comments on videos
consistently yeah some of you might
comment once in a blue moon but these
people like most people I know have
never commented on videos who are doing
very well who are very productive who
are very happy in life they don't have
time to be spending all their days
commenting sharing their opinions on
things that really don't relate to them
so I asked myself who are the people
commenting then if I've never met
anybody personally commenting all the
time who are these guys are always in
the comments some of them are
emotionally invested in in what you do
and what you do what I do and they love
us so much they want to share positive
things which is great we appreciate them
that's great whenever when Patrick was
on Joe Rogan's podcast I commented hell
yeah I loved it so much Miss child to
Patrick but David man thank you so much
so there's people you felt inspired to
make a comment but then there's most
then there's people then there's the
trolls then there's those individuals
gotta pay the troll told who don't
comment out of inspiration yeah but they
comment out of anger out of frustration
or sometimes nitpickiness yeah or
nitpickiness so this they might say
something like
um you after everything you said they
might be like yeah but hafiz's shoes are
untied yeah it's like yeah yeah really
bro everybody's talking about
accountability yeah and being the best
version of yourself you're focusing on
it shoots 100 and shoelaces and then my
thing is that I need those comments in
real life if you want to comment and say
something about me please people know
I'm in I'm in Dallas I'm I'm at bottle
blonde I'm at citizens yeah yeah that's
good I'm there pull up pull up
many many people have pulled up yeah all
great things I don't I don't see those
comments I need those comments in real
life yeah for me to address them but
we're here we're here let's address some
of the comments yeah what a lot of
people who are in the Redfield community
have a
a lot of followers in the red pill
community
don't like my representation of the red
pill Community okay and for those that
don't like you don't know the red pill
versus the blue pills those other
differences I covered this with Rolo
tomasi but please recap so let me
explain something
to the people who are going to be lost
in the sauce
when it comes to this conversation it's
such a post-modern conversation and what
I mean by that is in post-modern English
language words are subjective okay right
so because words are subjective things
don't lack objective meaning anymore
right so for example let me give a
simple one yo what's up dog
what does that mean depends dogs mean
homie dog can mean piece of s that I
don't like right it's subjective but
what has happened is the language has
broken down so much that two people can
let's just let's use a word and get
people fired up abortion some people
abortion means ending a fetus yeah
people abortion means any in life
there's two different people that that
war has two completely different
meanings pro-life pro-choice and they've
and there's so many other things you can
Define and these words critical race
Theory yeah what does that mean to you
some people in me you know so that's
what happens red pill is one of these
words where there's a bunch of people
who Define it and there's a bunch of
people who also Define it and they're
battling so another example or the best
example I give is feminism what is
feminism when you ask people who are
feminists feminism means the advancement
for women advancement equal rights for
women right you ask people people in the
red pill Community what feminism is
bashing men hatred misandry
what is it what is it it goes it's based
upon the receiver of the information so
I want to make it clear whenever I
Define the word I'm just simply defining
a word that there's not even an
objective definition yeah in the
community just made up by a community
yeah so and every person has different
definitions you have 17 red pill
creators all 17 of a different
definition of it so to me I'm just I
know in my opinion I personally know
almost everybody who I find respectful
in the space I know I can call them on
the phone right now talk to him as a few
people who I don't know personally but
if I wanted to I can call them and talk
to him on the phone I I I'm not just
somebody who I'm not a part of the
community I'm not somebody who just sits
down and shares I know your your
favorite Creator I know
so when people are like oh you don't
know you don't know bro the people
you're worshiping and learning from I I
can call them on the phone right now I'm
your favorite Creator's favorite career
yeah
what does red pill mean to you let me
get so red pill is this idea based upon
the Matrix right so in the movie the
major neatest red pill he woke up to the
realities of Life yeah so it's waking up
to realities of life but then it's
realities of Life about what usually
when the people talk about red pill
online it's realities of inter
um personal relationships and the
Dynamics between male nature and female
nature so basically what is the truth
about male nature what is the truth
about female nature and what is true
about how those two Natures work
together in relationships so that's
basically understanding red pill what is
the truth about inter gender
relationships between men and women
that's what the red pill means but when
somebody makes a statement and they said
this is the truth it's the truth
according to whom yeah exactly you know
to me if I'm telling this is the truth
is the truth according to whom like like
reli like like Christianity is the truth
according to Christ Judaism is the truth
according to Moses perfect Islam is a
truth according to Muhammad if you know
um
everything so so it's a truth according
to whom so what red pill creators will
say is the truth based upon scientific
studies and research that has been
gathered together and Men all around the
world will come together usually on
these Message Board in early 2000s they
will come together and share notes So
Adam will be like yo I dated these five
girls in Miami and this would happen and
Dave was like yo I dated these 10 girls
in New York this would happen let's not
give him too much credit for them thanks
Adam two girls in New York
and so the idea was that this what the
what became of the red pill is this you
know
this
combination I was thinking about a word
but I couldn't find a word of all this
information and it's the truth about
male nature male nature female nature
interpersonal relationships
but it's based upon what your favorite
Creator tells you it's the truth gotcha
I I to be honest I I've seen The Matrix
I remember that scene you want the red
pill or the blue pill
um
it was uh what Lawrence Fishburne I
believe that uh gave me the option
Morpheus yeah but I actually interpreted
more the red because people started
saying as we're doing the PVD podcast
and I tend to be more Center left I'm
thinking more of just a moderate in
general uh moderate in everything but
people would say oh I don't get red
pilled yeah so we're coming more of a
republican yeah so now I'm just yeah I'm
me yeah so so red pill I think can also
be politics yeah so if you were a
Democrat and you open your eyes how
Democratic establishments X Y and Z you
can become a red pill about Democrats if
you were you know maybe blinded by woke
politics and you're now starting to see
that it's wrong you can be ready so it's
now become more than that but usually
the guy is online the guys are
commenting right now they're usually
talking about it in relation to
interpersonal relationships and the
truth about interpersonal relationships
especially in the modern era yeah so
quotes on the truth and it's the truth
and like I said they will tell you it's
based upon the objective studies but
when you ask a more majority of these
guys show me these objective studies
that you know these quotes because I
know all the data yeah I know everything
that you guys know I follow all these
people there's a reason why when they
come on my podcast one of the guys come
on our pockets he was like yo you did a
lot of research about me and I'm
impressed I said it's not research I
just know this stuff as much as you do
I've been in this as long as you I've
naturally being a person who helps men I
learn from everybody I've researched
everybody I've researched a very
religious guys the secular red pill guys
I've learned from everybody some very
well versed in all types of languages so
what they're always communicating to me
is that I misunderstanding them but I
believe what they're doing is they're
believing in ideology that's being
communicated to them by individuals that
in my personal opinion are not leading
them in the best Direction yeah and
they're so dogmatically trapped in this
in this ideology whether they consider
an ideology or not and so when I make my
criticisms of the ideologies like me I'm
a Christian if somebody criticized
Christianity because I'm so dug into it
I'm gonna push back they're so dug into
these ideologies whenever I criticize
them they're not going to be happy and I
understand it
[Music]